Russia is by no means as powerful  in energy as it thought it was and  actually you know to take a step  backwards  it's an illustration of a sort of wider  and deeper problem for Russia is that  Russia's leaders and Russian people tend  to massively overex overestimate their  importance in the world they actually  really you can call it a superpower  complex or whatever but actually the  reality was that although Russia was in  fact the biggest energy exporter in the  world it would actually accounted for  about 10 percent of world's production I  mean that 10 is significant but it's not  90 it's you know it's not enough it's  enough to cause inner serious problems  uh for for Europe  um  and cause a spike in in gas prices that  we saw over the summer but it's not  enough to bring Europe's to its knees